um we'll make a start
yeah can I hurry up
welcome everyone to the finance and
projects committee meeting the public
session today 15th of August
um and so we do have some apologies um
from councilor Campbell uh Barney and
also councilor Bond so I'll move those
thank you ringy and seconded barrier who
was in favor
aye those apologies why do we need Toms
we need Toms times a minute committee
sorry
thanks for checking the night Sir
um okay uh any Declarations of interest
in relation to anything that's on our
agenda today
okay there's no public us I will
probably uh step out of the old on the
KFC
Holdings yeah I think most of that's in
public excluded isn't it
okay
but thank you for noting everyone
um right no public forum so minutes of
the
findings and projects committee meeting
held
the council chambers on the 20th of June
3 P.M
next week
any
discussions or
items are rising from those minutes that
we need to talk through
yeah I have a few
um
so probably
how are we structuring the minute so we
capture the action items out of those
minutes
who am I asking that too
Michael yeah so Mr chair of the minutes
capture what was discussed if there was
an action that was to follow then they
generally captured as part of uh the
discussion sections
um if there's an action you believe we
have missed then
please advise and we're happy to make
those adjustments
yeah so yeah I suppose if you look at um
likes of page Ada board books the
discussion around this building
I mean I think there's a reference in
there about a report coming back
and there's often a
reference to a report coming back but
it's not clear when the report's coming
back
that's big so Mr chair
um that would be because if Council
hasn't asked when the or given a
direction is to win the reporters to
come back uh
the chief executive and his officers
will work to ensure that a report does
come back but we don't have a timeline
there's no instant assumption that it's
the next meeting yeah unless it is
requested that it be at the next meeting
um
Better Home events
I can assure you if it's noted in there
then it is captured yeah and it is an
action for
the chief executive and the officers to
follow up with but it's yeah and this is
a specific date requested by the council
laws or when you expect to see that
report
um it is at the discretion of the chief
executive when he brings that back okay
yeah and it's not questioning officers
it's more just trying to keep the
consistency around what we're you know
reports coming back and we can keep the
management of those actions and again on
page nine I think this with this talk
through there about you know walking a
price in East Street whisk and there's a
comment about the paper coming back but
there's no reference room where we're
going to receive that so I think
you know probably what we need to do as
counselors is just if we're asking for
reports then we've got in mind when we
expect to see them back and then staff
will give us guidance room when they can
be delivered
but certainly for this without committee
I'm Keen to see that disciplined
developer
actually just for you just to reinforce
a couple things here
um these minutes that we've got now are
far better than we used to have there
used to be very much condensed down and
we're lacking detail that will suit me
my experience on the last term
um and we had in the last term some
discussion around
you know we don't want verbatim
reporting because that just makes the
minutes millions of miles long as it
were
um but we do need some accuracy in here
and and the lack of accuracy
um is our Airline making I think as
Michael quite rightly said so a good
example of you raised was the issue
about the um this building and the need
to upgrade the building and having a
report come back but you'll see in
today's dashboard reports that are
coming through from the pmo they
recommend a workshop so disappearance
yeah and so the fact that we haven't
said we want a
um a paper-wide x date so that we can
then have a workshop as our making not
the staff making yeah for sure yeah and
like I concur
um I think the minutes you know when
you're reading through them you very
much can recollect what's been recorded
and they're they're not verbatim which
we don't want so you know we I think
they are right but it's just probably
taunting up on some of those other
aspects and I think it's our duty as
much as the office's duty to make sure
we're clear on when we expect to hear
things bigger yep uh Leslie and the
endurance
thanks Mr chair I was just going to say
in the cab
issue
my memory memory was in the discussion
that we recognized that we were asking
for a very comprehensive report that
would take time yes and that there might
be an interim update but we but we would
not have expected a report by the next
meeting and in fact I I my memory may
have even
been that we discussed the probability
of the need for a workshop as part of
the developing of quite that
comprehensive report yeah so while it's
not
while it's not entirely recorded that
way in the minutes I think it's it's
recorded pretty much as we left it that
it was going to take more than a meeting
yes yeah absolutely yeah Darren I just
kind of makes that point Leslie did I
think the workshop was to help
Define what the information or we'll
find out the information that was going
to appear in the subscript report yeah
yeah that's just about the business of
getting things done really uh me just
following on about
um the accuracy of minutes
um we had the example of the Great South
shareholders meeting where a statement
statement was just made the chairman
briefed the committee on a subject now
if we passed that on or are we
is that something I mean obviously it
would be great to have consistency
across our organizations that minutes
not just us but whether it be wasting it
whether it be
Great South whether it be anything that
we're involved in and we we need that
consistency if we're going to see the
standard for our minutes that we receive
then we need the same feedback we need
that coming back from our other
Partnerships or whatever you like to
call them yeah and it's probably
dependent on those organizations so so
it will be us saying it would be good if
it came to be but we're not the only
partner in this organization sorry
there's going to be a minimum standard
of someone's got to draw the line and
set the bar what is the minimum standard
well but equally don't set that standard
by yourself yeah I think eagerly it's
irresponsibilities cheers to make sure
that we are comfortable with whatever's
coming through here committee through
the chair can I ask Michael Morris if
what the standard would be
expected you know so each
I think has been discussed each Council
uh sits their own
expectations on what they want to see in
their minutes we will have different
expectations to our partner councils and
Gore Southland and the Regional Council
that being said we can always go back to
those councils and say that our Council
has expressed disquiet about the level
of information contained in
into joint committee here
um minutes could we see
um some more information what is
reported in that what does the ACT say
or is it silent the act the ACT is
silent as long as the minutes capture
essentially the resolutions it's up to
council to determine how much as as you
will know and it's been discussed we
used to do verbatim back in some time
ago we had moved uh in the last term
more to resolution focused which were
very very concise and now we've sort of
come back to more of a middle ground
following the direction of this council
at the start of the term that you wanted
to see
um more information captured so you can
follow what had been discussed but that
is the decision this Council has taken
I I can't give that direction to my
fellow governance managers and go south
at another Regional Council and it would
be inappropriate for me too but I can
express this council's views on what
they would like to see going forward
let's just start thank you yeah and
equally it's the cheese responsibility
to make sure the minutes reflect acrylic
for me
so the last three or four conversations
have just reiterate the fact that we
need to be clear about what we want yeah
Darren quite rightly said um the
workshop would allow us to identify what
we want in the paper you could argue the
reverse as well that if if we're saying
to staff look we may or not be in this
building one three five years from now
whatever the figure is it would be
helpful before we start making some
decisions about that to know from staff
well hey if you're not staying here
these are the short to medium term costs
that we've got some costs around this
building that are here right here and
there and I don't know that no no I
think there's a workshop next week yep
yeah okay anyway thank you good
discussion everyone's awake now so
that's good
um we've got to move in a second of
those minutes so um being that they're
acceptable can I all those in favor
aye aye against carried okay strategic
projects report
welcome Lane
afternoon everybody
good afternoon I think what I'll do is
I'll just um
cover off
government report first and then we'll
dive into the dashboard that's uh
agreeable everybody it's obviously in
this cover report I've made a few
um statements around
um some of the pressures we're starting
to see across the program and this will
be reflected in the dashboard and we'll
talk to the individual projects as we go
through the dashboard
what's becoming a little bit more the
norm for us at the moment is value
engineering and still seeing
um some cost pressures in the industry
pushing against what
we could probably deem as normal rates
and these are normal rates that we've
cast in the last 12 15 18 months but
we're seeing pressure against those
rates
um increasing so
that's something that we'll get we'll
get a flavor of as we go through the
dashboard but I just wanted to sort of
reiterate that in the cover report that
we are starting to see some
freaking and groaning to budgets across
a number of our projects and we see this
in what we typically term as our cost
plan so as we come to as we go through
different phases of design we put a cost
to that design
um we look at we reflect that against
our budget that becomes what we determ
as the cost plan and we keep updating
and monitoring the cost plan as we move
forward until then we get into
construction so that's some of the
terminologies that you'll see in the
report and that's the meanings meanings
behind them
so a cost plan you know for some
projects we may be on the third or
fourth cost plan and this is just a
reiteration and update as More Design
information comes forward and the
quantity surveyors cost that
we're really starting to interrogate
actually where some of these pressure
points are and we we we're trying to
track them back to source and a lot of
that is you know cost of living
inflation we're still seeing significant
um
logistical problems here in New Zealand
with getting sourcing material and still
a number of you know fairly standard
commodity items still being quite highly
you know quite highly valued you know
we've had all that problems with jib and
stuff like that and they have ease but
they haven't eased as much as we were
hoping and they're definitely aren't
getting into getting anywhere near
pre-covered level so that um those
inflation and those
pressures I suppose that post covet is
still lingering with us and where some
countries have seen them eased we're not
seeing that um that that easing here in
uh let alone New Zealand
some of the items we've actually started
to really sort of drill down in and
we've actually stuck we've started to
see cost spikes of 20 plus percent
especially around sort of plant and
equipment so as we've started to deliver
it's free and you know that's flying
along you know we're just getting some
Intel through our contractors there that
there's they're carrying they're
carrying a lot of weight on cost
fluctuations they're not seeing any
relief especially in some of that
technical stuff that's coming to our
Shores
um and like I say some of that stuff
will be priced in 2021 is now 20 plus
more here now in 2023 so they're they're
the realities that we're tracking we're
aware of them and we're just really
drilling down into the detail of them
which allows us to make good decisions
in the future
other part of my
um
cover sheet obviously we talk about
forecasts and I think the last time it's
that year we were a little bit under
forecasting and now we're probably
spending just a bit above our
forecasting and that's the trend that
you'll find as we go through design
phases as we get to end of design phases
we tend to drop a little bit below our
forecast and as we start to get into
physical construction onto the sites
we'll we'll possibly go above our
forecasting spend so that's typical ups
and downs of screw in design and through
physical build so I think overall the
forecasting has been quite good within
the team and we're trending trending
trending well in that space
and I think other than that the cover
report is reasonably straightforward
than that but I just wanted to stress
some of the terminologies and stuff
before we get into the dashboard any
sort of comments on the cover cover page
so um as we go forward and you redraft
or re-price some different escaping or
design work
um
we've tended in the past to have 10 15
as a contingency Fund in
it would be wise to have a percentage
slightly higher than that
it's an interesting conversation about
contingencies and we have it all the
time the problem with contingency you
take it out of the value of the asset
that you're designing so you you can
limit what you're trying to achieve by
holding more back just in case the dark
day comes so you've got to try and find
the balance there of keeping an
appropriate amount of contingency or
letting letting that contingency
go a bit in design and that's sort of
the approach we're probably starting to
take up more so with the museum where
we're holding what we believe is a fair
amount of contingency but being fair and
reasonable with the designers to say we
might let we might give you some of that
contingency in the design design phase
if we need to hit a particular outcome
so yeah you could be super conservative
increase your contingency holding but
you'll limit what you'll deliver
possibly in a physical build because
you're holding that budget back
so it is
so so putting aside the the museum which
I think is quite a unique yes it is yeah
because of external funding
um as opposed to some of the other
projects that are predominantly funded
through our capex yep
um I guess I was just signaling that
maybe as we go forward what's an example
we might want to remediate um rugby park
program you say can we have a ballpark
figure in here once we start getting
closer to the date that we start doing
the work we might increase the
contingency margin because otherwise it
just constantly shows that we're over
budget yes and we report that and it
just seems to the public that we're
incompetent that we haven't been able to
forecast out and that's not the case but
that's the perception I guess yeah sure
come back to museum in a later stage
yeah
um there's a comment here which I
hopefully is not related to the museum
um you've you've said we're in a good
position to Pivot to design yeah
um does that mean you're changing the
design of the Museum oh look at this um
we'll talk about that a little bit more
in the detail of the each individual
project but because we're starting to
really investigate where these Source
where the source of the pain is coming
from whether it be plantar mechanical
electrical stuff like that we can start
to look at those places uh and design
differently or change our scope or
change our want
um by means of being pivoting it's yeah
it is changing the design is
understanding where those pressures come
from and being able to change scope
change the outcome change what we're
designing change materials focus on
different types of materials whether it
be wood concrete glass
um so yeah no pivoting is is changing
our track is changing our tank I would
be very concerned about that so perhaps
it's an opportunity to discuss it later
um yeah I can give you some examples
maybe as we talk through them yeah but I
mean
so just before we go forward so just
Keen to take questions specifically on
the sort of overall pmo view before we
dig into the project so as yours related
to you know it was more or less about
Tristan said
um I'm just a bit worried we're going to
be yeah downgrading Air Museum yep cool
right so I've just realized that the
material costs and everything have gone
up so for my business as well
um and probably labor costs will go up
in the end as well so yeah it just
worries me away but yeah okay we'll talk
about it later
so near yours was specifically related
to the museum or is it related to
generally I've got two parts to it so
the just on the general part I'll take
that on you and then we'll go to knobby
when we started with the museum trash we
um
we gave the pmo team some discretion
around the size of the complex we had
three options that we consider and one
at the lowering I think from them it was
about 1300 square meters and the top end
was about 1800 and we sort of created
from memory about 1600 to 1800 which is
still a a big piece of real estate but
it gave them some flexibility if they
had to to claw back but there are some
other specific factors that override
that as well which is we'll talk about
when we get to
the specifics of the museum
right
um
through the chair when would be
appropriate time to talk about projects
that aren't on yeah nails now yeah okay
look
um coming from my position as chair of
infrastructure we've got the CCTV one
now it's a significant project and I see
it would be equally as significant as
quite a few of the ones
listed on there is is there a reason why
it shouldn't be on there or should be
there or on this particular dashboard
yeah well this is predominally projects
of the pmo are delivering but whether we
look at
additional dashboards that cover all
projects
something we consider but it's not been
delivered by the pmo so if that's why
it's not on this particular dashboard
yeah it's probably a question I had a
two around it and I think there's some
really good disciplines in within the
pmo office and when you think about you
know if it's something big
infrastructure projects
um even roading you know
um whether or not they could be managed
you know so there's better line of sort
across how those projects are tricking
because that big Capital items so better
think Michael you want to respond yeah
thank you through yourself cheers So
currently we have
um two sets of programs that come up
through this committee uh one is the
Strategic capital projects which
um are the ones that tend to be done
through our po team and those are the
ones that are listed before you most of
those items are the ones that are on
your roadmap um Council roadmap
um the other renewals projects run
through different pro programs and
aren't on that Report perspective they
do come up in your quarterly performance
report so you get the full list there
and and able to discuss any of the
projects from that that perspective
but the other one is the enhancement
program that's an internal program that
we generally bring up I I believe it's
Miss this particular one because we're
reworking the report
it is something we are adapting and
looking at and then something into the
future that we will be looking at how do
we get a better overall Council project
reporting but I do know we want to
continue to bring up the key roadmap
projects in the short term while we
continue work on that reporting
yeah okay
um the reason I ask is just going back
to the June infrastructure meeting we
got a
um a timeline given to us for the CCTV
project now we're right we're right into
it now and we are in that timeline and
it's just an important thing there are
key phases and I guess questions to be
asked along the way and there are some
obvious gaps in the timeline so that
would be oh I suppose we'll just leave
it to the infrastructure meeting then
it's all right
well yeah and the other one I had is um
is probably the East Street whisk uh
West you know you know that's an
important project for the city to
deliver this
so you know that and I think the CT TV
is another really important project for
our community and to me it's you know
yes we can cover them in infrastructure
but if we see all our projects in one
particular sheet that are really
important to us it's you know gives us
better oversword and we can sort of
overall calibrate where we're at with
our projects so with the air Street West
since you've raised it where where was
that set because the key thing was to
work with the I guess the developer
because on the limitations that may have
been able to been achieved
and I spoke with katahi at the
conference and they're very interested
in I've been coming on board in the past
uh three self-cheo just uh remind
councilors in relation to East Street
West that's still being worked through
to actually form into a project at this
stage it is not an existing project on
your roadmap it will need to be
established as one um through through
Council approval process we do have
funding aside for stage two in relation
to your streetscapes work and that will
need to also be clarified in relation to
what that's allocated to as part of that
I'll remind Ryan Council the um that the
current form of stage two was put on
hold pending a review and we will be
coming back shortly in relation to what
that means for Council so I would
believe that will go via the
infrastructure committee from that
perspective for fiscal in relation to it
is focused on street and infrastructure
Works under the ground so
yeah but I think that you've hollowed
the point it'll be good to know that
that's just where we're at with it you
know so
set visibility that we need is
consistently
you know some feedback are we just don't
like not ringing and Michael are both
said I just I feel that if
Lee's current dashboard could include
those other types of projects even
though they're not delivered by the pmo
I think that would be a One-Stop shop
for knowing where we're at with a lot of
things like yeah it'll be very helpful
yeah and I for me it gives us one window
look under the opportunity into the
council around what are the big things
that are important to us that and where
are we at with it they may not yet be
projects but they may be waiting for
this and at least we can know and I
think as Council gives the opportunity
to go back to
you know rate payers and keep them
informed around when we're I think look
I think just we'll take it we'll take it
back as feedback and take it back into
the team and we'll work it up from there
yeah
thanks Mr chair my only comment on
adding those projects into pmo is that
it's actually a total change
from what we asked
the pmo to do at the start and what
we're funding pmo to do and if we're
going to add in lots of
non-payer mode delivery projects it
seems to me we're just creating more
work for Lee and his team and possibly
duplicating what's actually being done
by the other staff who should be dealing
with it so I think it's not
as simple as saying add these other
projects to the pmo list
I think it's something where we need to
ask
the CEO and possibly Aaron as the team
leader in the area
um
what is the most sensible way to to
report without duplicating because I
just don't want pmos to be overloaded
with adding and projects just for the
sake of having things
but I'm actually non-controlled by pmo
on one page
it just seems it could end up in a lot
of duplication that's not necessary yeah
and I think that's my worry that's what
we've just done we've asked them to
reflect on it seen the disciplines that
Lee and his team are bringing to you
know the projects that are specifically
related to and then is there some stuff
we can pull across to the rest of the
organization to make sure we get good
momentum
well yeah through yourself to you that's
a very good point the councilor roses
um because I wouldn't have Lee sitting
up in front of you reporting on things
that are going on and in relation to
some of the roading projects Etc
we do need some time to work through
that report we haven't provided that
report in the past except through our
quarterly reporting
um and that color reporting is the full
project list but it doesn't go into the
detail that you would want in a project
reporting and we're mindful of that and
we want to get to that stage
um should we
um get to the stage that we've got to
report to that sort of detail you won't
just have one
pmo manager sitting at the end of the
table you will have a whole heap of
managers that you will need sitting in
the background to be able to ask those
sort of questions or a very up school GM
GM table who who know exactly which each
of the projects going so we'll need to
strike a balance and get the right
information through to council we are
working on it quite quickly I I hope to
have it within this calendar year
that's that's very much a focus of ours
but it is it's requiring a resource that
we currently don't have on the books to
actually do the work so I'm I'm waiting
to get that resource the the currently
in a vacant role yeah yeah and that's
good to hear I suppose just for a
company ringing in the interim how do we
you know because the feedback I'm
hearing here is the councils want good
oversight of where we're at with
different things that are on there that
have been ticked off and we're at some
way through the process they may be
sitting in pmo they may be just okay
well we've identified this as a priority
for Council now let's work through a
process so that's the thing we'll
probably even feedback on ringing look
just a comment then to make life easier
for the pmo would be take Bluff vote
ramp out put a turbo structure
I mean I don't know why why it's sitting
there because you know infrastructure
clearly an infrastructure
that project was transferred to the pmo
um to deliver so that is when we are
delivering oh
and it's going really well so it can
stay there
oh a bit of consistency but I see the
point you're raising and it's yeah it's
a good point
just as a final reflection um
we've been slow on updating our
community on the CCTV the last piece of
advice we gave was that we'll have them
in place by the last quarter of this
year where
getting very close there yeah depending
on where that wording meant calendar
year or fiscal year probably meant
calendar year so we're already there and
there's no evidence of going up and I'm
not pointing the finger at anybody
that's not the issue the issue is
communities crying out for these cctvs
got a whole rapper she's coming to us
including
um
Chamber of Commerce and people out there
and the police and the other issue is
the issue of s Street West that's got
some significant consenting processes to
go work your way through we are going to
get right up against that new hotel
unless we get started on that pretty
quickly that's right yeah this works
first here
just wanted just to provide some clarity
around which projects are included in
the pmo and and why generally when we
set up the Strategic roadmap we looked
at those as being strategic projects
across Council usually those that were
upwards of four million dollars or a
number of smaller projects that were
considered to be the stone in the shoe
projects the likes of the Anderson house
and the bluff boat ramp
um those that we've just been struggling
to get traction on and had been pulled
in for that reason so that's just been
the makeup of that strategic projects
list once a project goes into there to
deliver it really needs to stay in there
to deliver there can obviously be
decisions made around bringing other
projects into the pmo but that obviously
needs to be balanced against the
resource because you also don't want to
split the focus of those other key
projects
um and sort of spreading that resource
thinner and thinner yeah and again you
hold on another really important point
where we're having the discussion
because you know we shouldn't be waiting
till projects get a bit skinny before we
pull them in and get something done
around them we want to make sure they
are so yeah yeah and so usually that's
that four million and up projects that
we would look to put in straight away
yeah
okay
next part which is actually
dashboard yes the dashboard yes
any questions on the dashboard
I can go through
I'm going to go through them through the
projects are I think pretty much it's
should have been read so yeah questions
I can start it off the team
um
the
the museum storage facility you've
talked in there about relocation risks
just in your commentary
um in the ongoing gaps and information
in planning what what are you talking
about there yeah so we set out or the
relocation team set out on on this
journey and they created a plan
aka the relocation plan and we put we
fed back into that plan
um with quite a quite a few lists of
questions and there was a lot of
assumptions and and that made
uh on how they were going to go about
the relocation timing of that now stage
one's being done
um what we've asked is that plans now
Revisited
um now we have some knowns we don't know
how the stage one's gone they've got
some tangibles and we think it's really
important now that that plan is updated
with the with those tangibles those
Lessons Learned and then delivered back
so we can be comfortable and confident
that stage two which is critical uh for
a the demolition of the museum but
obviously of you know fundamentally
aligning that with the storage facility
yes
um Coming online as well yes so that's
uh we think that's a very key document
that now needs to be picked up tidied up
and represented back to the
game office yeah and it got some
scrutiny around cost and that sort of
thing too didn't it it did yeah and I
think that's you know but you putting
all that together now there's a lot of
hypotheticals yes now we now we know
what we know yeah so it's time to get
their report okay thank you
Evelyn
uh yes
I also had a question about the storage
facility but it was about the reference
to
um things costing more so
just in terms of some of the specialist
equipment did we not pre-purchase that
at the prices that we had quotes for so
some of the things like the shelving and
things like that yeah so for the um for
the storage facility actually
financially it's tracking really well
because we contracted that in a very uh
tidy Manner and it was a guaranteed
maximum price and we went out to the
market and contracted that in that way
with that contract tool so that's uh
that's a fixed price that's at that
price that it's holding
um the good thing from that is that we
can get Intel through talking to our
contractor of where that where the pain
gear where the Pain's been and that's
this is where we've picked up the intel
on uh HVAC and other other equipment
they're seeing a bit of pain on that as
a contractor but it's a guaranteed
maximum price so that one actually is a
fixed price and where that was
performing well
okay so that was a that was a positive
lesson learned in absolutely but
unfortunately because of the web Market
is the way it is and and look at some of
our bigger projects you're not going to
get away with you know a guaranteed
maximum price with some of that some
contractors
um there'll be always be some
flexibility and we talk about maximum
price contracts and you talk about
guaranteed maximum price contracts and
they're all very different things and
all they mean is in a very technical
sense is how variations can occur so um
and I won't go into the detail of that
but
um yeah no Tisbury was contracted really
well and Performing really well so the
infuser to that the only reason for the
orange light is because we're now at the
second stage of
um transfer yeah we're just yeah we're
just flagging that once that plan is
tied up I'm pretty sure that light can
go green because I think what's we're
going to find out when we go through
that um relocation plan part two is that
time we assumed we needed for stage two
we're going to need a lot less because
the teams really performed very well in
stage one
thank you
anyone else another Barry sorry yeah um
let's have a question about the boat
ramp is uh is this a resource content
management problem or just something
that's just come up on us no no the
resource consent has been a little bit
slower coming through than we wanted and
it has slowed it has slowed our uh
original timeline down we've got the
draft conditions now which is great but
we're still waiting for the rubber stamp
so we can get get into it and onto it
um so we've got we got we got
contractors and pricing ready for to do
the piling work but until we have a
stamped rubber consent we can't
physically get into it so it is a little
bit disappointing that process has taken
a bit longer right but foreign
how many units is that that's four four
units
any other questions
Okay so we've got uh can I hit the Mover
and a second to receive the Strategic
Capital project report receive the ICC
pmo Pro
program dashboard
and note the current status of the
report please rang it in very okay all
those in favor
aye against carried cheers
okay
next on the agenda is the
um
risk management policy and I think
that's Rhiannon is it
welcome
Kyoto councilors
um so
this policy is brought forward
essentially to combine a lot of separate
policies in order to make them more
usable there are a small number of
changes that are proposed since the
policies were reviewed by the risk and
Assurance committee and those are
clearly marked through the
um report
um the risk Assurance committee received
the policies favorably and felt it was a
good step forward in terms of
implementing Good Financial practice I'm
happy to take any questions
are we just a couple Rihanna
um
in one section on page 22 of boardwalks
you've got a cap of 300 per night for
accommodation has been introduced which
I support
along with a requirement to use
preferred providers where possible and
I'm not sure what that last piece
actually means so to give you an example
um
I've been into Wellington recently aware
of the organization is paid in the range
of 300 to 400 for
um Nitro combination and I happen to
stumble over Ibis which is downtown
Auckland and sort of central to
everything you'd ever want to go to
which has a maximum of 180 a night and I
think that and I suggested to the staff
that were doing the booking that I'd
like to go there again but I think
they're not a preferred provider I just
don't know what that last bit means do
we have
people or providers that we use that
give us reduced rates or
it's at an ease of booking that we just
use the same ones over and over again
so long as they're under 300 well
ibis's
40 under 300.
sure I'll refer that question to
um Patricia
um through you yeah
um we have a number of um Hotel
providers around the country that we
typically use and they have been their
preferred suppliers but I will take that
feedback back to the team about
potentially offering some other ones and
some key cities where we are finding
some challenges on that 300 limit
like the location was perfect and the
quality of combination was excellent
I just thought there's some potential
savings for us there and the last issue
for me is on Section same page section
169 that you refer to the entertainment
and Hospitality expenditure has been
removed as an allowable use of
hospitality practice and so just felt to
be inappropriate
in a council context and I'm not quite
sure what that is um
so it'll give you some examples
um
the mirror doesn't have a um a budget
whatsoever and I don't have any issue
with that I think you're going to be
accountable person you're spend but
there is the odd occasion where you have
somebody in town that might have come to
a meeting here at their cost and taking
them out for a meal at the end of the
end of the day it's actually quite a
Quant appropriate sort of thing so I'm
not sure where that quite fits with all
that because I'm not sure what the
allowable use of the hospitality
practices actually means
Patricia again potentially I'm just
quickly
through to 1.6.9 oh sorry oh yeah
assuming yep
start with on page
um 22 of the report itself yep
so you can and 1.6.9 allows Hospitality
for relationship building representing
Council recognizing significant business
achievement and replica
receiving Hospitality that you've
received in direct or clear business
purpose success so what we're taking out
is that the previous policy had if you
were taking someone out for Hospitality
in the hope of the making revenue for
Council from that relationship
so we felt it was unnecessary to have
that in there as a separate that the
revenue catch in there because you had
enough other ones with the camera
all right
same spot
thank you
um anyone else
right
um just touch on koha or gifts or
whatever obviously um the mayor
it's given gifts you only have to go
into his lounge and uh look in the um
the cupboards there's an accumulation
large accumulation of
bottled gifts oh not that large
and and it's a shame that these gifts
obviously I mean Nobby doesn't but they
it's it's a waste to see them they're
going to end go end of life and
disappear I mean the yatsaki you've got
some stunning wines and everything like
that and they are basically I'm gonna
just die uh expire and it's a shame you
know that if we aren't we should have a
policy that that if we're not going to
use them in some format of ceremony or
whatever is that can we can we at least
see them be used by someone and it's
just it's just
me as a passionate
um lover of of
alcohol no
I'm looking forward to your Solution on
this one yeah
it's terrible you must just yeah
pour down the sink you know it would be
great because unfortunately you know
they you know knobby's not gonna crack
them and they've accumulated so there we
go it doesn't have to be sold today but
it's one of those things that it'd be a
shame to see them just I mean there's a
brilliant Butler Pinot who are there
from from the Hawkes Bay and it's it's
going to go in a couple of years so
it'll probably already gone before
Central otago Pino Michael
we're happy to bring something back to
council at that stage about the
reappropriation of those particular um
gifts but um what I would highlight to
council is we do have an ielt and
um rules need to be followed in relation
to re-gifting of anything Associated to
alcohol in this particular region so I
just want to remind Council that but we
will bring something back
um two Council so we can have a
um open discussion about that can that
people the 20th of December
[Laughter]
if you would like that minute to
absolutely
um I mean either going to waste it or
just yeah you can cheer that committee
too by the way
uh Lizzie had Lizzy first and then
thank you I thought I would just point
out that perhaps
it's on page 20
spousal of surplus assets might be
something that could be slightly
expanded
I had a note on that that we need to
have Market appraisal within that piece
of the policy so I'm not sure the two
are toys but the end comment on page 22
is that sometimes Market appraisal may
be inappropriate and yes over costly yes
that's right it may there may be a
balance point in there yes
Nobby look good example is uh where this
stuff goes a little bit of rice
sometimes I mean I went down to the
Indian Independence Day celebration
today and they gave me a small gift and
it was just a drinking mug about that
big that you put your hot drink and it's
got a lid that you can twist around and
drink out of
and it's got across the front of that
Indian association of Southland what do
I do with that if I take it personally
home and I could use it at home or use
it going down the road to get a
Starbucks or whatever
um and then I'm seen to be using
something for personal use
do I just sit in the cabinet somewhere I
mean just
I think there's a whole lot of gray
areas in there a good example is when I
inherited this this job term over
probably a couple of decades it's got
three bottles I think they were sake or
something then there's really very good
Saturday yes it makes blue bottles or
Chinese was it sorry yeah Chinese
um and look maybe just sitting in the
cupboard and they've been there for as
long as I can remember so I dispose of a
couple at Christmas time with the staff
members and with with my colleagues only
to find out later on that each bottle
was worth three thousand dollars
but again if you just sit it there it
just eventually gets the stage you can't
do anything with it yeah so yeah yeah
the people that give it to you expect
you to actually use it I think when it
comes to things like yeah those sort of
gifts that someone online you find an
appropriate time to use it as opposed to
just sitting at the cabinet until it
gets past its life day yeah that's right
Evelyn
um
for the um for clarity's sake
and gifts and benefits are two different
things that's why they have two
different sections
um koha is more although we could
receive KOJA
um
somebody could give
Courthouse stuff to council
um for
whatever reason if we if we were hosting
um
another
Maori organization or Maori councilors
from somewhere else or things like that
they would potentially come with a koha
so it's not always just us giving for
her but this they're quite different and
um
just so is the public watching know that
we understand the difference I think
it's important that they're actually
section two is koha section three is
gifts and benefits yes
yes
Community would love to see Navi walk
around with it yeah I'm sure being used
yeah I mean if these things are given to
them it should be used and that should
be written down some of it's appropriate
one to do that and you should also
decide what to do with the drinks if
there's some drinks here anything small
lights have a bit of a shindig for the
people who work over there or whatever
you know I think it's uh those are sort
of some decisions that you should be
able to make yeah
so in the example raised by the mayor
the policy speaks to this matter on page
39 and 40 of book board books
um so in that example
um you could declare that gif but it's
of nominal value so yeah absolutely
appropriate to yeah
um
receive it
yeah the probably the most important
thing is the Declaration as much as the
use isn't it
um
Leslie thanks Mr chair I just wanted to
comment that if it happened to be Su
Chen yang hee whiskey when we visited
their their sister city we were shown
the um the brewery where that was made
it's a it's a huge complex with 30 000
employees and they have stored uh Yang
hee whiskey that is a couple of hundred
years old so I don't think anything that
was gifted to us in the last 30 years
was a problem for age
I'm in North here we put that thing in
the ground and we're going to be open in
50 years so maybe we could use that for
the museum
I think my meaning for age was that not
only going off and the sense of the
psyches and the whiskeys but the actual
use and actually wine will expire
whiskey will not expire but that's not
the point the point is just leaving the
emails you know dig a hole and put it in
there and cover it up because if you're
not going to use it I mean the idea I
mean I mean I think it's ludicrous
thinking that they're using their using
the comparison of a 200 euro whiskey
it's not it's not the point
the point is that it's going to sit
there not used and it's a waste of time
yes yeah it is and it's embarrassment
because if you're the people who give it
to you and find out that it's never been
used the feedback or whatever then
you're you've created another problem so
it's not an easy one but no
what the policy's been updated and it's
you know it gives good guidance in my
view so
right any other
knobby just two quick issues uh Rhiannon
or Patricia can help me with the first
one which is the issue of credit cards
um
so some of the credit cards that we have
are around sensitive expenditures which
I have to sign off on and so Michael
won't mind me saying this because this
is not his issue but I sign off in his
credit card expenditure all the way
through
but what I face in a lot of occasions is
actually just what's on the credit card
bill that we get from bnz or whoever it
comes from and it doesn't tell me a lot
so I just wonder whether it talks about
receipts and things which I'm not too
worried about but it's more about
um what supplementary information do we
have from the staff when they asked me
to actually
son at all yeah
um some cases I get that some cases I
don't so whether that's part of the
policy already I don't know
so so there is you get yeah I'm through
your chair there is um staff who have
credit cards actually undergo some
training on how their obligations of
having a council credit card which is in
relation to reporting so I will make
sure that the ones that you are seeing
that those members have are reminded
about their obligations of actually
putting it what it's for and that
because that is the key aspect that we
actually need to be able to do sensitive
expenditure reporting apparently well I
guess what I'm saying is it's not the
staff that have got the credit cards for
me because I looked at Michael's Uncle
him and I looked at it today and one of
the lines in there we couldn't work out
what it was actually for
um and so I had to go back to the staff
and Michelle quite rightly said to me
normally I would give you an email that
says here's the credit card account can
you please
authorize it or prove it even though
it's already been spent which is an
appropriate thing
um but we need to have something about
what it's wanting because audit will
pick up on us they'll come back to me
six months later and see you authorized
that what was the foreign
but that's weird
um through YouTube yeah um that is where
rather than just receiving the statement
there should have been the work paper
that goes with the statement that
actually outlines that so it's just
getting that process correct for
authorization yep thank you and moving
forward there'll be a technology
solution that'll capture that when we do
an enhancement program that's that's on
the one of the um possible items on
there yeah so you actually have to code
very specifically and reference it works
really well obviously yeah yeah and and
the last issue is the uh the very end of
the report it says next steps it says if
the draft policy is adopted and the
words that are missing there should be
by Council
because at the end of the day we might
adopt it today but that doesn't mean
that this goes forward it's still going
to go past
full Council to be adopted by Council
I guess
yep
um you smear is correct and that's why
the wording of the recommendation to
council yes is this committee recommend
yeah yeah they're trying to policy to be
approved by Council yeah okay so Donald
peace sorry I'm just a wording thing
that I just remembered and it's on page
five of the actual document
and it sees that this policy is to be
reviewed every three years
um but it refers to
the finance and projects committee and I
think it should have a rider that says
or its appropriate successor
because three years time will be a
different triennium the Committees May
well be renamed
and that's just my nut peckery sorry
yeah getting this note
right
um can I please have a mover and a
second to resolve that we received the
financial risk management policy
note the opposed the opposed amendments
to the existing policies and the
provision of the newly formulated policy
and approve that the draft Financial
Risk Management policy
approved for adoption by the council
thanks Leslie very seconded all those in
favor
aye against carried okay thanks very
much Brianna that's good
wanting to update Patricia
just as a reflection of what we
discussed at the very beginning of this
meeting was I mean I raised an issue
about
um the 300 limit for help for
accommodation
and the staff said that they'd look into
that
but again if we just adopt the paper
does that recommendation that the staff
have accepted just disappear into the
Blue Horizon
and I'm just wondering you know when we
adopted something like this we also
somehow put a rod on this is subject to
the following things being yeah provided
before it gets to full Council otherwise
I'll probably end up raising the same
thing again here's my two Michaels here
I'll go this Michael first thank you
through yourself to you and that that's
monitored and noted that we need to
provide a response so it'll be in the
minutes that we've said that uh as
Council staff that will take that action
on so in all those cases that that
should be what goes through the minutes
and that's the case where if it goes up
for review Atlas committee the next time
around they can be checked to make sure
that they have been noted in any
um but we do check that thank you thank
you I was essentially going to say
something similar and we do have
something that manages to track our
actions there arise out of Council
meetings
um and Michelle has just reminded me
that we used to have an action sheet
that covered all these sort of things so
we will
um continue doing some more work on this
um then I'm certainly a valid point
okay thank you Patricia
um cure counselors this is a financial
update
that does um show what a treasury
position is at 30 June as well as the
indicative management result for the
year to 30 June I say indicative and
management because there's still a lot
of water to go under the bridges we've
go through audit and finalize the
financial reporting to get an annual
report result
so
from a treasury position we are
currently sitting at a net debt balance
of 65 million this is still pretty much
in line with where we said we're just
under where would be with the ltp
and we continue to have a small
um policy breach in relation to some of
our borrowing just as we're waiting to
renew some borrowing and look at some
board swaps to meet to then the June
26th June to June 27 period
based on current projections we're going
to be at just outside our policy bands
for fixed and floating deep
foreign
my comments till we do the performance
report which is the next one on the
agenda but there are some additional
analysis there
um on certain items which aren't covered
in detail in the performance report
and if there's any questions
no we've got two two issues for you
Patricia um one that relates to the Ico
loan which you've got on page 51.
um so two things in relation to that I
guess just just so the public know
um eventually loans like this do get
paid back don't they
and and do we know roughly when there's
likely to be I mean I've heard of
figures banded of 10 to 15 years will
start to get positive cash flow which I
guess we'll just assume that there'll be
some
paying back off of the loans
the term of the slide is
um up until December of this year so
there has been discussion around this
Council table that we would consider
accepting that
and the other one is just more a
bookkeeping exercise which are the self
remarkable you can grant good answer if
we were in any of our organizations too
uh convert loan to equity does that then
uh that reduction in the loan does that
then improve our net debt situation
no no it doesn't okay
it worsens any dips yeah okay we still
have borrowed the money yes and we've
converted it to equity it changes the
balance sheet on the entity that we've
converted to or ice in this case it
would be ICL but yeah we've still got
the money we've borrowed from the bank
and haven't repaid so
it's fixed enability and this is nearly
I don't have any expertise on around
findings
um
thank you for that
um I would have thought if we borrowed a
dollar to invest uh to invest for one of
the better words in a project
that is something that we borrow and we
have a cost for that that's borrowing
against cash
which is what that's considered in the
formula and it says borrowings and other
debt versus cash and cash Investments
that's the equation
whether we get um
the money back from the
um
from the detangle I would have thought
all from the investment angle wouldn't
have changed that net debt
Am I Wrong consuming that
so through your chair
um that cash and cash Investments is
it's the equivalent of cash so if you
were to have an office let's put it in a
house situation an offset mortgage you
had some cash sitting in one account and
your loans sitting another you could net
them off
if you've got a an air case we consider
those asset loans
to be like cash
so we can offset them if you don't have
something that's cash generated that
looks like cash you can't offset it
which is equity which is equity okay
thinking or an asset you notice that
we've borrowed for Capital we don't
offset it
so if so this has got a borrowings those
borrowings at the top half of page 53
and board books a lot of those have
funded capital projects so you're not
needing off the asset that you've got
only if we've borrowed them for
liquidity purposes super cash so one
final question just so I'm clear going
forward
so if we have Equity it's not dead money
because I would have thought that Equity
gives us a greater share in the company
that's one issue so as they pay back
um as you get positive cash flow we get
a better return by having more equity in
the company
or if we went to sell our involvement in
a company
that Equity increased Equity would give
us a greater Return of the overall sale
of of the asset
all right that's fine thank you
Michael
I just wanted to add one sorry Patricia
it's um
through yourself tier it's just a Nuance
in relation to local government around
the um
Revenue that you earn in relation to the
debt because local government is
assessed on revenue for its debt cap
not only do you lose that the the
ability for to apply that that
investment today
the revenue also lowers your debt cap
the loss of the revenue that you're
receiving in relation to that debt so
you you do get hit twice so it changes
in both spaces so we're very mindful of
watching that
um that's hence why we don't like to
invest in
um Capital via borrowing terribly much
or and cheers because of that particular
impact but
just want to highlight that because um
particularly ones that don't have a
significant return because then that's
where you have that issue yeah if
suppose here was making uh paying us a
dividend then that would help us
no three soft yeah absolutely yes yep so
when Michael refers to through YouTube
when Michael refers to the debt cap just
want to be clear that that self-imposed
debt cap that we have
as opposed to the debt cap that would be
allowable by our Revenue under the local
government funding agency
it is both that's fine
okay thank you any other questions
yeah I've just got one which is in
relation to uh Saving Grace where we've
we've signaled a hundred thousand
dollars supporting a project but for my
recollection that's one of two one of
three payments of the same size
we've done one and we have two more in
the future
so I'm three chairs there's only one
more to come that's all we've done two
three there's a hundred left two Okay so
we've done 200
. so
um Saving Grace Council decided at the
time of the last ltp to allocate one
hundred thousand dollars to be picked up
in the appropriate year let's move
forward each year because
um the um project hasn't yet reached the
terms of the funding and there's a
report coming to Council on this matter
at the next council meeting
I'm not sure that answered the question
I thought and I might be wrong on this
but I thought we we
proved a hundred thousand times three
all up
no it was one payment of one hundred
thousand thank you
so just a further question Renault
Patricia so when where are we look have
we got any idea when they may meet the
criteria to receive that payment there's
a paper coming to the council meeting
next week next week revamp regarding
this matter right okay
any other questions
naughty just the last one on dog
registrations uh the report says um we
have 663 animals
um not registered
unpay
is an element of that
dogs that are deceased
or are they just dogs that we've
previously had reads that are no longer
I had a question on that too where did
you get your number from
that number comes from page 58 of yeah
but you said there's the amount of dogs
that aren't registered did you
well on the third line down it talks
about relating to 663 animals all right
so Patricia that has come from a
time so that's
what I believe is the population okay
um that will be tested in the coming
months as they seek to follow up those
unpaid dog registrations yeah so yeah I
had a similar question around so it's
just what was registered versus what's
now registered in the game they do look
at things as I understand it like the
age of the dog so if there's a dog
that's not registered that is getting
old
might be ceased have you got something
to eat there Jonathan uh it's three UK
no I don't think I can add much more
than Patricia's given you it can be
difficult sometimes to track down
whether dogs are still alive but it's
it's one part of our process
to check that part out so there is work
being progress in that area at the
moment
I suppose the other mechanism would be
that how many dogs are we picking up
that aren't registered is that growing
with that's probably another indicator
of how many dogs are running around
unregister is it
we measure that do we yep so um through
you again chair that's something that
we'll look at we can report back to
Council on that as we identify it
yeah and I guess my last question there
was the issue of the current legislation
preventer for having installments given
the cost of living that many dog owners
are facing
um is there any way around there or is
that well we stuck with the legislation
because it would seem a way of helping
some of these families to reach their
dogs yeah it's a good point so again
through UK yes we've identified that
issue and that's actually a project
we're currently working on to see if
there's a way to make it easier to
alleviate that
um there'll be some more information to
come on that shortly yeah
do we have a way of
assessing with the dogs have been
transferred between different
jurisdictions in other words do do your
different computer systems talk to one
another no they don't it's up to the dog
owners to report that yeah I do believe
there is a national register from memory
some really
cool unless someone says they have
transferred from another
um
Council so yes um we currently rely on
the dog owner to inform us I solve this
again we are looking at another
initiative that would allow us to track
it ourselves which would be a vast
Improvement on the current situation
guaranteed you have something or
it's
difficult
for us to work within what we're
legislatively required to do with
dog registration fees because
they're set by the government
um
and I'm a bit loath to shift the
responsibility over to the general rate
pay because
despite what a lot of people feel owning
a dog I'll say is a right it's not it's
a privilege and a responsibility and you
know there are vet bills and and feed
bills that people
need to be aware of
um I understand that times are tough but
if I go into Zed to fill my tank they
don't show a great deal of leniency
okay can I have a mover and a second to
please to receive the financial update
um
August endnote the current state
appointment it says thanks Leslie Darren
secondary all those in favor
against carried okay next one up is the
update in Patricia
welcome
random
oh sorry yeah sorry the performance
report yet
so um kyota again counselors
um this is the call of four performance
report it's important to note that it's
the end of year summary but there is
still
um various elements that need to be
checked as part of the annual report
process so when you receive the annual
report that will be the final statement
for the year
um some of the um key things to take
into account for this year is um good to
see a lift in the levels of service over
the previous year and we can see some of
this being the return of the
post-covered environment in terms of
leisure and Recreation particularly
being now returning to the levels of
performance with visitor numbers
um the other thing that I'll draw your
attention to is another big year of
capital program delivery so if you look
at the chart on
um page
62 of board books you can see there the
trend of capital delivery over the last
few years so while it is not the full
100 of the planned program at the time
of the adoption of the ltp the Auditors
did make the note of how ambitious the
capital program was
um
Patricia you may have other Financial
elements that you want to draw attention
to
we're sitting at a opening operating
deficit of 8.7 million
um this is actually slightly better than
what we thought it could be it's about
three million better at the moment
um and that's mainly because of some
additional ability to recognize some
additional subsidies
um and that's predominantly the better
off funding for um his bread
for the Tisbury project we've been able
to recognize uh some of that
um is it June
from that where it will change but but
the capital program is probably
something that we need to 51.1 that may
still move a little bit as we go through
those final changes
the apple bit that I was actually going
to raise was the recognition of how low
our cost of debt has been for the year
we've got a 2.88 average borrowing rate
that will go up significantly in the
next 12 months but that does mean that
our operating costs have because
operating costs include fighting the
interest costs are much lower than many
other councils with a similar debt level
than ourselves
thank you any questions relating to the
report or comments yeah I've got about
15 of them
um so it might be helpful for my Pacific
level we just work through each section
as we go through because there are
different topics so if I go to the first
one
um
which is on the very first page of your
report Rihanna
um which is uh recommendation five it
talks about year-end review and
adjustment including selected asset
revaluation and Council share waste net
are still in to be considered so before
ranging us because I'm sure he will
um
waste net currently sits on about 1.4
million dollars worth of Reserves so in
our bookkeeping do we have our share of
that sitting
um in there as a reserve or as part of
our
net debt I guess calculation because our
share is probably in somewhere north of
seven hundred thousand dollars
future but um comes in as their
investment in a
second okay um we do consult
is when we do this thing but it will
show up when we give you the draft
annual report okay
um on the road in kpis
um it says
um
three kpis are missed
and uh it talks about um
the kpis for routing around this and
serious accidents is
um world leading and inspirational kpis
around zero deaths I mean this is a
little bit like being
cigarette free by 2025 or excellent
fatality free by wakakote by 2050. it's
an absolute nonsense to say that on our
roads in our lifetime that we'll have no
serious accidents and no deaths and so
if you set targets too high you're
constantly reporting that you're failing
and and I think it's a discreted to
Russell and to others that he has some
very good results in the rating kpi
areas even though everybody butchers and
moans about um about potholes
that gets very good results in but he's
undone by some factors that may be
Outsiders control
a couple of factors that might be
outside the controllers is driver
Behavior which we we can't determine
alcohol use people that are not happy
with the current speed limit reductions
and want to speed a bit want to go a bit
faster when they're driving
um
or whatever it just seems that if you
have these inspirational 100 sort of
targets you set yourself up to never get
there
so I just wanted to reflect that and I
think he's got some good results in that
area
are you still going to stay on that page
sorry are you still going to stay on
that page around your comments
are you still going to stay on that page
go I've got a couple sure yeah
um just nice to note that um sort of
waste the Improvement there for the five
kpis and equally that um
the
um
High satisfaction around Parks reserves
and libraries I mean that's really good
to see
um I know how much I go on a better
parks and that sort of thing and it's
great to see a community really building
those assets because they're a really
important part of their communities
the other comment I make on on page 60
of what books as well is the regulatory
services
so close your ears from Jonathan because
at 96 which as you read a bit further on
is actually 98 because and a couple of
cases um
um the consultant didn't stop the clock
on the 20 working days which is a bit of
an oversight to have 98 when I can
recall when I first started on Council
was about 40
um
um it's quite an outstanding result yeah
it's getting that well done
anything else next page
um so what page are you on now I'm on
61.61 aboard box yeah Financial
operatings
um halfway down that page it talks about
employee expenses and some of the
vacancies we have all
um and our inability to get qualified
staff and I just wonder whether that
opens up
um
an opportunity going forward for
internal training which is upskilling
Staff into some of the more technical
areas than they might actually be in at
the moment
or internships
and opens the door for
um
for ewe to come into this picture where
they've got higher than they expected
teenage unemployment with some option
that we can't invest in those areas
being mindful that you can't bond people
but I think
we've got to do something other than
just sitting there
um you know and knowing that we can't
get some of our technical stuff that we
may need to invest and potentially
invest in tertiary area as well yeah I
think we've raised that last week in the
workshop didn't we or was it yeah last
week we had talked about their people
policy didn't we and Joe's coming back
with a paper at some stage
um look at just like to remind Council
as well the um wonderful work with top
attorney in relation to um
bringing through the youth through that
program
um there's a lot of landscapers that
will come through that particular and
Forestry workers from the uh hopefully
from them they're learning some
wonderful skills for their futures
um so that's one Avenue where we've
we've partnered with another
organization to achieve those goals but
absolutely we're looking for
opportunities and it is something we
have on our our mindset and how we
attract
workers that we can actually take
through the training and we we do
actually train some through our
organizations uh at the moment we've got
an example of a number of people that
have had multiple jobs as they've gone
through as they've trained up and then
upskilled themselves into different
levels within the organization so that's
we're actively working on that and we
are working on a people's strategy for
for the organization ourselves so that
will take a little bit of time to get
through we need again it's a bit like
the um our other report there is a
vacancy in the one that's supposed to
work on that but in both cases we of
those vacancies we're hoping to fill
those in the very near future so we'll
get that work kicked off and get it
going yes
foreign
answered my next question but part way
down it says Council still maintains one
of the lowest average borrowing interest
rate in the country at 2.88 so I guess
so just looking for confirmation that's
because of our credit rating being as
high as it is
no okay come through chair now it's not
only the credit rating yep um it is just
the at the point of time we were
borrowed worth fixed interest rates were
fixed for periods at very very low and
so as those start to roll off and they
are starting to go through a period of
rolling off we will go up and join the
rest of the month but our creator rating
must also help
um yeah a small amount but it's not this
the main reason it's just okay where
where we've borrowed at what point in
time we've borrowed yeah yeah it will
have an impact probably going forward
because credit risk is being priced
higher so if we're at the bottom end or
the top end of the curve in terms of low
risk then we will get a benefit as
opposed to some other
your Hunters
let's keep going yes I'm on the page 85
now for those who have not kept up over
them really racing ahead racing ahead
which is the routing service and just to
reinforce and what I said before I think
as we go forward enrolling and and I'm
in the commentary part there that talks
about for those that are online a number
of fatalities and series industry
crashes continue to be of concern
um and Council staff are working
alongside road to zero based on a vision
of zero a world leading approach to
societal commitments to work towards
zero harm on the roads and I just think
as we go forward setting a hundred
percent there is just sitting Russell
and his team up to fail
and I'm not asking for any changes now
but certainly when that comes around for
negotiation next time around which might
be the next long term plan or the next
annual plan to give some margin on it
because when you look at how he hasn't
achieved
um
to have one fatality and I think 14 17
17 serious Excellence
um you'd argue that most of that stuff's
beyond the control of a rating manager
I mean there might be some element of
potholes there might be some element of
the nature of the service of the of the
raid and that all comes out in cranial
type inquiries but
I mean there's just no way that in a a
TA this big that we're not going to have
a fatality or a serious accident on any
one 12-month period that's right
well uh throw yourself chair and look I
have to reflect on that one and say
there's a number of
um kpis that councils have upon um
legislatively placed upon them and this
is one of those kpis which we're not in
in the position to be
um able to put in a different one it's a
message that's being sent that the
target for the whole country is to
achieve that they use the reporting to
actually go across all regions to say
where they've actually had them
um it it does mean that we are setting
something from a Target perspective that
is very ambitious and uh obviously we
continue to work towards it as a council
but having said that I acknowledge the
um challenge so that places on our
particular on my team
and the cost implications Associated to
doing that but life we can't have
anything lower than 100 From perspective
of what kotahi because what's one life
with and that's where it gets taken into
account I don't think you can say 99 or
something from that perspective yeah
thank you Leslie then Trish
thanks Mr chair I was just going to say
I have to support Michael and Russell on
that
one of those performance
by the DIA any any discussion of trying
to change that performance measure would
have to be in a very different form from
this one we are bound
we're Bound by the fact that it's one of
those performance measures that's that's
set needs to be set
yes it is a challenge but it's a
challenge that Russell's um report there
and what Michael has said
um shows that we're taking on and
monitoring very closely but
but as a performance measure
would be an entirely different Forum
that would have to change that
performance measure and
that is highly unlikely because it is a
very ambitious World leading Target
that's had significant investment in
being set the way it's been set
as Waste Management Solid Waste
Management so there's two issues in the
commentary of like some clarification on
halfway down it says while improving
each quarter the diverted material rate
remains below Trend so is that is it a
statement on behalf of the city
or is it uh wasting its
um overall material rate is below trend
are you going to answer the question or
you've got a question
oh hang on sit in the queue yeah so
someone want to put that question up
Erin
I expected Rhiannon was probably going
to send it in this direction so grab to
the microphone in anticipation uh
uh whilst uh this performance report
speaks currently to our city trends
um that trend of when we talk about the
trend we're talking about the five-year
Trend
um both from a waste net perspective and
for an invercargill city council we are
still sitting below that five-year Trend
Mark
um however obviously we've had some more
positive results this year than we have
in the previous year so we do appear to
be trending back back into a good
position but below the five-year trend
thank you and while I raise that chair I
guess it's important to reflect that
I've previously commented on wasting it
being a three Council effort and if
everybody's not rowing at the same Pace
the old Walker doesn't go far enough
forward and quick enough
rainy did you want to jump in there I
think it's a good analogy it is it is a
while going it's a two-hole walker
unfortunately
the holes are pointing in opposite
directions
um with the uh with the waist one
um this must relate back to the
council's waste minimization management
plan that is our that's our Bible for
what we need to achieve and how we're
going to do it
um I don't see that matching it
um the uh the plan has to stipulate how
you're going to achieve it
and with that it should set those those
critical goals that you monitor every
year
so
I think I'm I'm along with me I I really
don't see those comments coming
relevant to the plan at all
of of the waste you know going up down
whatever
the the air Waste minimization
Management plan has to be far more
detailed and prescriptive than just
comments like that
um and I have a second part of that
commentary as well for you chair
um at the end there's a recycling costs
have increased due to the increased
termination contamination volume so that
raises two issues for me
um which again
um
we're grappling with as a city as part
of the wider waste net one is the glass
contamination which infiltrates the
potential to on-sell
um paper and cardboard and to some
extent
um can damage Plastics as well
so
wasting it are looking towards what we
do with glass but the other issue is in
rainey's racists before is what actually
comes in on the recycling bin sometimes
just has to go off to landfill the whole
lot has to because
I mean range about photographs I've got
photographs of it as well what people
are disposing of in the in the wrong bin
is terrible and while we're doing an
education stuff through wasting it which
is initially pitching at schools I've
heard other Council say well not
everybody's got somebody at school and
if we don't dovetail out with some
degree of Bin inspection and enforcement
action we'll be talking about this 10
years from now
so I guess that's a challenge going
forward as well yeah but we've we've got
some
um reports coming back through
infrastructure haven't we Aaron
at some point re-wastenet
the reports go up through wastenet and
then the minutes come to infrastructure
committee and then obviously are open to
discussion through infrastructure
committee yeah no no but in terms of
some of the sort of things that we were
might look to do around glass recycling
those sorts of things we talked about
that last infrastructure meeting didn't
we and but again the reports will go to
wastenet and then back through to
infrastructure committee
at the moment ICC doesn't have a ICC
specific role with solid waste
everything that we're doing Solid Waste
wise primarily largely with the
exception of the recycle contract
um goes through wasting it and then back
into the various different councils but
didn't we have some discussion around we
do some test and learn sort of stuff on
our own
to just troll some
absolutely so that we've taken on board
those suggestions but again they'll come
back via wastenet so when's it likely to
come back so there is a report initial
report going to wasting it on the 11th
of September
so the team the wastenet team have been
working with Bond Contracting around
getting together what a glass out
collection would look like for the three
different councils that's been we've
received initial costings for that we've
just asked for some different options
and variations to be looked at to come
back to that we've shared those initial
costings with the two other councils and
then we'll present a high level road map
to waste net governance group on the
11th whilst noting that we are still
finalizing those dollars and cents
conversations with exactly what the
service would look like the other key
piece that we've got in train there is
around the consultation because
obviously this is something that we
would need to go out to the public to
consult with it's a key change of
service that needs to be coordinated
across three councils and rhiannon's
team coordinating that discussion as
well and then we can look to how we
would Implement that service up if we do
so following the public consultation
period so and so that would come back
more after it's been through wastek
through infrastructure wouldn't it at
the initial piece would when it comes to
us going out for our consultation is
invercargill city council that'll come
directly through infrastructure because
it will be in invercargill City specific
so that would come through the
infrastructure meeting in September uh
no it would not come through I believe
until October Rhiannon will be able to
confirm that we're still finalizing the
plans with the other Council so can't
give a specific date at this point okay
okay thank you thanks for the overview
look um
I don't know how many times I've got to
bring this up but the waste minimization
act 2008
stipulates that a council must have a
waste minimization management plan that
is prescriptive in what it does
currently our plan was done in a in a
rush and it was during covert so it was
very difficult but the plan does not sit
with what we're trying to do
so I don't know how many times I've got
to say it but we need to get our wmmp
sorted so we know where we're going not
do stuff ad hoc
so I I mean I don't know whether they do
these acts and everything just for fun
but I thought they were reasonably
important and with statutory law
but but isn't that something that would
be picked up through infrastructure
well I said it at the last meeting when
we had this discussion that the wmmp
needed to be
on right on key on target not the
current one we have
so here's the frustration
um we are one of I think three councils
out of 67 that don't do glass recovery
parts of Christchurch parts of Auckland
but the other two
um
while we go for consultation
um it may be that many of the people
that give us feedback will say hey
there's an additional cost here that we
don't want to wear and write
then what do we do with that
given that I think we have an obligation
to separate glass out like everybody
else is doing so that's the first issue
the other issue is is that we we tend to
go through
um
through wastenet and the other two
councils in wastenet have different
views on glass recovery
ones opposed and one's looking at an
alternative
so that leaves us having a need but
we're still funneling through Wasteland
which is guess what ring is eluding that
doesn't sit within a plan for us and I
guess the other issue is the issue is
that Bond Contracting has been sold I
understand
and so I'm assuming that the contracts
the bond have run through till 2027 that
was my understanding
so if that is the case and we want to
add glass which is a substantial cost
which is another round of pickups
are we Contracting or asking Bond or the
new owners of bond for a cost this is a
question for Aaron I presume
or is that something that we would need
to put out in Tinder
given the limits that we have on yeah on
Contracting yeah well look I think we're
deep into sort of an infrastructure
discussion now so is the mirror and is
the chair of infrastructure I'm probably
going to put it back to you guys to say
you need to come to
your respective committees and council
with you know with the we we know the
issues because we've consistently
heard them and I think the council has
given a very clear Mendo where we want
something done but we need those
committees to come back to us with easy
resolution and this is where we're at so
you'll park it there and leave it to you
too to wrestle with it Michael thank you
thank you through yourself to I was
going to say same thing but also we're
starting to get into commercial
discussions that will need to occur in
relation to a sales transaction so um
not willing to discuss it further at
this stage yeah okay okay Trish I think
we're at your page now okay I first like
to acknowledge the Excellence work
that's been done this year this is as a
performance report we should be very um
appreciative of the team that do this
and yes we congratulate it
um and on page 94 it says that to do
with housing here building which you
might have guessed it would be
um the lead designer appointment was
delayed by two months you know is there
a reason
I mean obviously the you know there was
a reason but you know we're going to be
careful about these things because it's
we're getting there are people at the
end of it who are losing out
anyone know the answer
I've read the leader's owner
sorry I was just flicking back between
my reports
um in terms of the delay with stir it
straight
um it was simply around timing coming
back for the design the project team
were doing their best to be able to keep
it on track but there was some some
slippage in terms of getting those
initial Concepts finalized to be able to
be priced yeah it just does seem ashamed
it does not that we we lose that time
um absolutely but obviously from a pmo
perspective they try desperately to keep
everything on track
um and it's not 100 perfect they're
doing pretty well I'd say overall across
the entire program particularly given
that it's been a program that's been
accelerated
um with some pretty chunky extra
requirements put on the team last year
um so yes absolutely we'd like to be 100
on everything but we have had some
slippage in a couple of the of the
smaller projects yeah I just had to
Mitch
um
Trish you and I have both had people in
the areas from the housing portfolio
um and a level of noise that's probably
much greater than it needs to be when I
look at the results that are in this
report from the housing division which
is predominantly our aged care
facilities the
um their ability to respond to requests
it's outstanding
um
I don't think any private sector
provider would be anywhere near the one
day and two-day responses that they get
through Council
nowhere so I think it's quite
outstanding
portfolio in lots of weight but it just
never seemed to satisfy everybody so
okay are we ready to move
so there's uh five
recommendations these receive the
performance report for the third to June
note the 70 to 99 measures 71 of levels
of service performance were achieved for
the year 30 to June 23 compared to 67
and the preview preceding year
um note the draft net operating deficit
for the year
is 8.7 million you know draw attention
if you haven't already just around the
depreciation impact on that note the
capital program
2 30 June 23 has delivered 51 million
this represents 96 percent of forecasts
and 64 of the planned program for annual
plan and note the performance report
contains provisional results for the
year and it's not the draft any report
the year in review and adjustment
including selected asset revaluations of
council share of waste net are still to
be reflected can I have a mover in a
second thanks Leslie seeking to Barry
okay all those in favor hi against
carried
so that concludes the public
section of the meeting so we will now
move into public excluded so can I have
someone to move in second thanks Barry
second Darren thank you that we move
into public school all those in favority